more issues near the port of los angeles  now we first told you yesterday that  neighborhoods nearby the port they're  filling up with some empty shipping  containers now some are even blocking  driveways and  one of those containers fell off a truck  and onto a parked car  neighbors say that was a concern now  it's a reality  i mean i came in and i saw the container  completely destroyed and top of my  brother's car in it honestly i was just  shocked i'm glad he wasn't in the  vehicle  boy isn't that the truth  store shelves unfortunately are still  empty efforts to get it all moving  they're slowly working president biden's  press secretary said since moving to 24  7 operations last week the amount of  cargo sitting on the dock for more than  13 days has been cut in half so a little  bit of good news there